author George's Diaz Montek Sano has
been researching this area for years and
he's convinced that some Atlantan
refugees fled inland and built shrines
to memorialize the lost city deciphering
the shrine would help giorgos prove his
theory no sir a real mental assent a
burgeoning comapre barkos picomolar Oh
Jose Ramon oh sorry mo Calhoun
according to George Oz the epic of
Atlantis is recorded in a series of
Stone Age petroglyphs images inscribed
in stone telling the story of a ground
city a legendary port and ships that
once sailed the Atlantic I think that we
shoot here but it has gonna mean the
cameras in really up there to test this
theory George's enlist the help of
engineer Ken Boydstun and professor
Gregory Hayworth experts in forensic
photography and spectral imaging
bringing lost images back to life yo
pienso que la gente que o Pina que esto
nos Aereo simplemente por que no se
donto milan serie o yo creo en a bouquet
arrested endosteum a sensei a cozia
aquella Jenga
[Music]
ready shoot Chitti
I'm using the strobe as a raking light
which will bring out the shadows and the
depth of the incisions in the rock oh
yes this is a horse with a long flowing
mane chewy I'm looking closely at the
screen and I like what I'm seeing I can
see the course much more clearly I'm
looking for signs of a horseshoe which
has a lip at the end and I see no signs
of a horseshoe at all which means it's
pre-roman that would be pre-roman oh oh
here we go okay yeah yeah there's a
bunch of stuff here the investigators
she wide moat like circles that surround
the entire scene I see a bunch of
concentric circles and in the middle of
this there's some roughly parallel
straight lines
concentric most like circles are exactly
what Plato reports when describing
Atlantis what's that line right above
the horse well it's a long wavy line and
actually there's a couple of them
there's one there one further one up and
they be mountains could they be Wade
clear water or it could be under water
the way to be the horse is tilted
downwards if it's under water
that could mean it's drowning and it
seems that it's not the only figure
beneath the apparent line of water
that looks like a boat that looks like a
boat up in the right-hand corner zoom in
a bit again this one here looks like
that means a whole that accent of a
whole of a boat yeah yeah and if that's
the hull of a boat that boats underwater
[Music]
you